[Music]
developing news this afternoon another
deadly crash on this holiday weekend of
travel right now roads near this scene
still closed so the collision happened
this morning this is near tanea and farm
road one woman was killed bianca holman
live at the scene of the fourth deadly
crash in our valley in the last three
days bianca
good afternoon john so this portion of
farm road remains closed while the
investigation continues this hour so
here goes a look and impairment is
suspected in this collision the driver
of this white tahoe was taken to the
hospital for minor injuries once he's
okay to leave he'll be arrested for an
alleged dui this all happened around 7
30 a.m metro says an eastbound toyota
prius and westbound chevy tahoe collided
head on debris can be seen all over the
roadway because of the impact the woman
died on scene and the driver of the
tahoe was taken to the hospital
if you're drinking you're doing drugs
you're doing anything that's illegal i
do not get behind the wheel of a vehicle
because clearly behind me you see the
destruction that's occurred that occurs
when you fall asleep or you're you you
can't see the roadway or you get blurry
vision whatever happens because of your
impairment you end up striking another
vehicle and you kill somebody and a
sorry is too late
lieutenant munson also tells us this is
the fourth deadly crash in their
jurisdiction this weekend there were
three deadly crashes on saturday in just
five hours again impairment is suspected
in this collision and he also says that
all of this is very preventable again
we're near gilchrist orchard at the
corner of tanea and farm road reporting
live bianca holman 8 news now